president Trump makes his big Supreme
Court pick and the left has a complete
and utter meltdown I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
there's certain days when this right
here it just keeps overflowing
overflowing and overflowing and today we
basically had a massive plumbing problem
because the leftist tears that were in
this tumbler just kept flowing upwards
and outwards in fact my feet are now
underwater I mean it's creeping up to my
knees that's how much that's how many
tears are coming out of this left is
tears hierarchal tumbler we'll talk
about all that in just a second first I
want to remind you that our next episode
of the conversation is almost here on
Tuesday July 17th at 5:30 p.m. Eastern
2:30 p.m. Pacific all of your questions
will be answered by our own Andrew
Clavin with our hosts Alicia Kraus our
live Q&A will be available on YouTube
and Facebook for everyone to watch only
daily wire subscribers can ask drew
questions in real time to submit those
questions log into daily wire comm head
over to the conversation page to watch
that live stream then you type your
question into the daily wire chat box
and have it read and answered on the air
by the way being a subscriber means you
always get to do that we had a live
episode last night on the Supreme Court
and you got to ask questions during the
breaks actually once again if you
subscribe you get to ask drew live
questions on Tuesday July 17th at 5:30
p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific and join
the conversation and hear about the
great good very good wonderful awesomest
thing that drew will talk about then so
go check that out also I want to remind
you that there are many times when you
ought to be worried about inflation
higher wages can cost it can create
inflation because they increase the
minimum wage across the country import
prices could skyrocket with the trade
wars raw materials prices could increase
with tariffs rising housing prices I
mean look at the bubble that's happening
in California right now and of course
the government could fix all of its debt
problems by simply printing more money
one of the reasons that you want to make
sure that you have precious metals is
because of all of this stuff protect
your hard-earned investments from the
tidal wave of inflation that could in
fact be headed our way
hedge against that inflation and hedge
against uncertainty and instability with
precious metals gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified yours should be as well and
the company that I trust with precious
metal purchases is Birch gold group
right now thanks to a little-known IRS
tax law you can move your IRA eligible
401k into an IRA backed by physical gold
and silver it's perfect for people who
want to protect hard-earned retirement
savings from future geopolitical
uncertainty and when you look back
historically what you see is that when
everything else becomes worthless bold
is not Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau you all know about for
Birch goals free information kit for
limited time qualified purchases can
earn up to an additional 10 grand
precious metals for free through July
31st to find out if your purchase
qualifies contact Burch gold now go to
birchgold.com slash been talk to a birch
Kohl's rep mention that I sent you
that's birchgold.com slash man do it now
the offer runs until July 31st terms of
limitations apply ask your sales rep for
details okay so yesterday was quite a
day everybody waiting on tenterhooks to
see who exactly president Trump would
pick to replace Justice Anthony Kennedy
on the Supreme Court and Trump did a
great job of holding that secret all the
way up until the last minute was only
about 45 minutes before the event that
those of us in the know know began to
figure out that it was definitely Brett
Kavanaugh does when Judge Amy Coneybear
was discovered back in Indiana so she
wasn't in Washington DC and Catholics
had basically been ruled out and and
then there were rumors that that
Cavanaugh was headed over to the White
House and that basically sealed the deal
the White House pitched this thing like
a reality show because that's what
President Trump does best they actually
put out a little 15 second clip of a
camera moving toward the White House
podium and then scrolling up toward the
microphone before it cut to black and
then it said 9 p.m. Eastern tonight and
then the question was who would get the
robe not the Rose the robe and it turned
out to be Judge of Brett Kavanaugh so
president Trump announced the pick
obviously having a fantastic time doing
it will talk about Kavanagh what he
means for the court in just a second
here was president Trump suggesting that
when he picks a Supreme Court justice he
does not act out asked that justices
opinions on on the law in keeping with
President Reagan's legacy I do not ask
about a nominees personal opinions what
matters is not a judge's political views
but whether they can set aside those
views to do what the law and the
Constitution require and of course
that's exactly true for a lot of people
on the right there are a lot of rulings
where it doesn't go the way you would
want it to go politically but it is the
way that the Constitution protects
things and Trump is exactly right to say
that about cabinets also smart to say
that obviously because people think that
Trump asked Kavanagh he'd overturn roe
v-- wade and Cavanaugh said yes and then
Trump picked him there's also a rumor
going around today put out by I believe
who's ABC News completely unverified
that Brett Kavanaugh was basically
chosen by Anthony Kennedy that Anthony
Kennedy when he decided that he wanted
to step down from the court when to the
Trump administration and said I'm only
going to step down while you're
president so long as you make Brett
Kavanaugh my success
that the mainstream media are pushing
that like crazy today suggesting that
it's it was all a corrupt bargain that
Kennedy was appointing somebody who had
who had continued to promulgate his
legacy even if that were true I'm not
sure I the left would be upset about
that considering that Kennedy was a
left-leaning judge on a lot of the key
issues including same-sex marriage and
abortion if you were appointing his own
successor you would think that the left
would take solace in that fact but in
fact there's no evidence that any of
this ever happened the reporter who
originally repeated the story said she
had no evidence that it happened she had
just heard rumors to that effect doesn't
matter the left ran with it anyway well
then Brett Kavanaugh gets up Brett
Kavanaugh of course from the DC Circuit
Court of Appeals we've discussed his
credentials in the past we've also
discussed some of the shortcomings in
his record we'll talk about what he's
going to do for the Supreme Court in
just a second he did a little speech the
president assured him up to the podium
and then Brett Kavanaugh came forward
and everybody went oh my god that's
pretty Cavanaugh's music and then he
sort of charged for the microphone and
then he proceeded to give a speech about
his background and his past and then his
judicial philosophy here's what he had
to say about his judicial philosophy my
judicial philosophy is straightforward a
judge must be independent and must
interpret the law not make the law a
judge must interpret statutes as written
and a judge must interpret the
Constitution as written informed by
history and tradition and precedent okay
the reason that he adds precedent right
there is because precedent is a fudge
word if you just said a judge must
interpret the Constitution as written
informed by history and tradition we'd
all say great that's Thomas's standard
that Scalia standard by adding the word
precedent he allows himself a little bit
of wiggle room so when people on the
Left say well you do overrule roe v wade
wouldn't you he'd say well listen
precedence is still precedent precedent
is a legal fudge horde and Kavanagh is
is fond of using it you know III think
that Kavanagh is in short a stand-up
double for the president I'm not sure
that he's a homerun for the president I
think there are a lot of good things
about Kavanagh I think that Trump could
have gone for broke he decided not to
but what Cavanaugh had to say in his in
his speech last night was exactly right
he talks about how he taught at Harvard
Law School who's actually appointed well
Lena Kagan was Dean there she of course
is on the Supreme Court now he's 53
years old he says that he teaches about
the Constitution separation of powers I
each that the Constitution's separation
of powers protects individual liberty
and I remain grateful to the Dean who
hired me justice Elena Kagan hey so he's
dropping Elena Kagan's name right there
because he's trying to win over some
some wavering Democrats also when he
says that he teaches that the separation
of powers protects individual liberty
that is him slapping at the so called
Chevron defense so as I've explained on
the program before there's a very famous
Supreme Court case called Chevron in
which the Supreme Court essentially
declared that administrative agencies
ought to be given almost complete
deference when it comes to the decisions
that they make about individuals so the
EPA decides that your toilet is now a
protected federal waterway and they
decide to find you based on that and you
sue the EPA and the EPA has an
Administrative Procedure you have to go
through the Administrative Procedure and
then it comes out against you so you
decide to go to the judiciary branch
right the EPA is in the executive branch
you decide instead to sue in federal
court Chevron deference would suggest
that the EPA could make the final
decision on all of that the the more
conservative judges like like Kavanagh
people who believe in separation of
powers believe that Chevron deference is
a mistake and that you can't give
executive agencies the power to rule on
the rules that they make themselves this
is exactly right and finally Kavanagh
says that he believes in an independent
judiciary I believe that an independent
judiciary is the crown jewel of our
constitutional republic if confirmed by
the Senate I will keep an open mind in
every case and I will always strive to
preserve the Constitution of the United
States and the American rule of law okay
so all of this sounds good and he's
saying all the right things to get
through a confirmation hearing what does
his record actually say so there are a
couple of areas where he's really good
one is on administrative law and one is
on guns he's excellent on guns so
there's an article over a recent
magazine by Jacob Selim who follows this
stuff and he points out that in a 2011
decision in which a three-judge panel
upheld the District of Columbia's ban on
so-called assault weapons and its
requirement that all guns be registered
Cavanaugh dissented and he said instead
that an analysis based on text history
and tradition is consistent with the
Supreme Court's Second Amendment
precedents he suggested that assault
weapons bans should actually be
forbidden by the Constitution of the
United States this of course has left up
in arms no pun intended
he says that when when the assault
weapons ban was formulated it included a
bunch of different features of the of
the guns that ought to be been he says
the list appears to be haphazard to ban
certain semi-automatic rifles but not
others there's no particular explanation
or rationale for why some made the list
and some did not
and then he concluded that the assault
weapons ban in DC was inconsistent with
DC versus Heller he said in Heller the
Supreme Court held that handguns the
vast majority of which today are
semi-automatic are constitutionally
protected because they've not
traditionally been banned or in common
use by law-abiding citizens there's no
meaningful or a persuasive
constitutional distinction between
semi-automatic handguns and
semi-automatic rifles so he's good on
that he also has ruled in favor of
people being able to spend money in
elections and corporations being able to
spend money in elections in Citizens
United versus Federal Election
Commission's he wrote an opinion
rejecting FEC rules that made it harder
for advocacy groups to raise money said
because donations to these hard money
accounts are capped at five grand
annually for individual contributors the
FEC allocation regulations substantially
restrict the ability of nonprofits to
spend money for election related
activities and he says that can't be
reconciled with the First Amendment now
where he's a little weaker is on fourth
amendment right so if you are a civil
libertarian and you're deeply concerned
with the government violating search and
seizure and reasonable
search-and-seizure Cavanagh is not a
justice you're gonna like very much in
2010 he dissented from the DC Circuit's
decision not to rehear a case in which a
three-judge panel had ruled that police
violated a suspected drug dealers Fourth
Amendment rights when they tracked his
movements for a month by attaching a GPS
device to his car without a warrant
he said the tracking did not constitute
a search because of the quality and
quantity of information so putting a
tracker on somebody's car doesn't
require a warrants according to Brett
Kavanaugh that rationale is is
interesting at the very least but it
shows that he is more of a law-and-order
sort of William Rehnquist a type judge
Rehnquist of course was Chief Justice of
the Supreme Court all the way up to the
point at which Justice Roberts became
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court if
I'm not getting that wrong in any case I
think Cavanaugh has been very Pro police
he is he is not a big fan of Terry
versus Ohio he's not a big fan of a lot
of these sort of civil libertarian
decisions that some on the right are
fond of he also is very anti Chevron
deference as I mentioned he does not
believe that the administrative agencies
ought to have complete power
everything that you do he says chevron
has been criticized for many reasons
there's a 2016 book review to begin with
it has no basis in the Administrative
Procedure Act Chevron itself is an a
textual invention by the courts in many
ways Chevron is nothing more than a
judicially orchestrated shift of power
from Congress to the executive branch
moreover the question of when to apply
Chevron has become its own separate
difficulty so Kavanagh is very anti
Chevron deference so on guns and on
administrative state stuff Kavanagh is
really really good he's a little bit
weaker when it comes to religious
freedom stuff maybe although that's not
completely clear in praise for life for
example he said that the government had
a compelling government interest in
providing contraceptive care to people
he said that even that compelling
government interest could not overcome
the religious presumption on behalf of
priests groups on behalf of religious
groups that wanted to have health care
done in coordination with their with
their First Amendment rights but he said
that the government did in fact have a
compelling government interest when it
comes to contraception and of course in
seven sky he was the the creator of the
rationale that suggested that Obamacare
was a tax and not a fine now in just a
second I want to talk about what
Kavanagh is impact on the actual court
is going to be because I don't think
that he's going to be the kind of break
it all down shatter every window destroy
wholesale the left view of the law guy
that some of them left fear and some on
the right hope but first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over illegal Zim
so if you need legal help if you're
listening to all this legal talk and
you're thinking boy you know it would be
great if I'd actually organize my
business properly well that's why you
should have worked with Legal Zoom and
you still can Legal Zoom was created
seventeen years ago and their mission
was to help all Americans confidently
and competently navigate the legal
system since then over a million people
have trusted Legal Zoom for business
formation but your relationship illegal
zoom does not end there together they've
put together a network of independent
attorneys licensed in every state
available to answer your questions
provide legal advice for your business
without billing by the hour since Legal
Zoom is not in fact a law firm which is
awesome as a business owner you have
enough stuff to worry about without
worrying about the legal stuff itself
and you need Legal Zoom to make sure
that you don't have to do any of that
anymore go to Legal Zoom calm right now
use promo code been at checkout for
special savings against Legal Zoom they
make sure that you got from soup to nuts
everything you need legally they'll do
everything from wills and trusts to
helping you organize your business and
they even have a network of lawyers they
are able to answer your questions
without you
to pay that ridiculous hourly rate go
check it out right now it's
legalzoom.com
and use promo code been at checkout for
special savings that's legalzoom.com
promo code then at checkout okay so what
does all of this mean for the court so I
said at the very outset I think the
Kavanagh is a double I do not think he's
a homerun on the political side he's a
double because the left is gonna go nuts
no matter whom and Trump appoints
doesn't matter who Trump appoints Trump
could appoint a chicken and the left
would go completely insane Trump could
inform appointed Merrick garland and
what would have said there's some
nefarious reason he's an appointing
Barack Obama spec he really it must be
the Merrick garland has secretly been
body-snatched and replaced with an evil
right winger that's how much the left
hates Trump the reality of the situation
however suggests that Cavanaugh is not
going to be this this wild right-wing
figure that everybody thinks he's going
to be and that's why if President Trump
was gonna get the flack anyway he may as
well have gone for Amy Coneybear
I think he should have gone for Mike Lee
Amy Cohn you buried someone you know is
going to vote a hundred percent of the
time in the most robust fashion on
constitutional issues I use the word
robust advisedly they're the reason I'm
using the word robust is because I think
Cavanaugh will vote the right way on a
lot of these cases but I think the
opinions of what she will be part the
opinions that he will help write the
opinions that he'll write himself I
think those are going to be very
narrowly tailored opinions and that
makes a difference
for the creation of precedent that makes
a difference for the creation of the law
now if you're gonna get in the fight you
may as well go for broke and by the way
it would've been great to see Democrats
attacking a 46 year old mother of seven
with two adopted children including one
from Africa I believe and attacking her
as some sort of evil fall back to
barefoot and pregnant in the kitchen
that would have been delicious
television and it would have really hurt
Democrats in the midterm elections as it
is I think the Democrats will be jazzed
up about Cavanaugh's appointment I think
Republicans are saying win with it and
they'll go through no problem but I
don't think it'll necessarily fire up
the base all that much I think a lot of
Republicans are gonna be satisfied now
okay so what does this mean in terms of
the actual decision-making well why does
it matter no decision is written it
matters how a decision is written
because if you write a very broad
decision then that gives you the
capacity to knock down a bunch of laws
at one stroke if you read a very narrow
decision you can only knock down a
certain narrow subset of laws at one
stroke so to take a particular example
in the last the last judicial term
there's a case called masterpiece cake
shop we discussed it at length here
the program the masterpiece cake shop
case is a case where a religious Baker
in Colorado did not want to create a
custom cake for a same-sex wedding and
there's a law in the state of Colorado
created by the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission that said that you have to
service anybody who comes into your
restaurant or into your into your
establishment and the ruling that came
down from the Supreme Court said that
that law was unconstitutional but not
because the law itself was
unconstitutional it was only
unconstitutional because the Colorado
Civil Rights Commission had applied the
law unequally in fact they had targeted
the religious person but they had
allowed seculars to go free basically
that if you were an atheist and he
didn't want to cater a religious cake
then you didn't have to but if you were
a religious person you didn't want a kid
or a same-sex wedding then you had to
and they said that's discriminatory well
that narrow grounds for ruling means
that there is still the possibility that
a state could pass a law basically
forcing religious people to cater
same-sex weddings and that the Supreme
Court would allow that to go forward
that's the problem of the masterpiece
cake shop case well in just second I'm
gonna explain why I think having it will
be more of that so Kavanaugh is very
much like Justice Roberts in the sense
that when you read his decisions they're
always very carefully tailored to the
law that's in front of him it's very
rare that he uses a particular law in
front of him in order to go after an
entire body of law now maybe that's just
because it's on the appeals court maybe
because you're on an appeals court that
means that you're not at the Supreme
Court level so you actually have to take
into account what the Supreme Court says
and you have to use what the Supreme
Court says as precedent maybe now that
he's on the Supreme Court he'll be a
little bit more audacious about striking
down bad laws in the name of the
Constitution but if we're gonna get a
lot of masterpiece cake shop cases if
we're gonna get a lot of cases that are
very narrowly tailored where he's very
careful about how exactly those cases
are decided and he doesn't go to the
root issue what you're gonna end up with
is a lot of confusion at the court of
appeals level and this is most obvious
when it comes to abortion so a lot of
folks on the right are very convinced
the Kavanagh because Trump pictum is
going to step in and strike down roe v
wade tomorrow I am very very skeptical
that Cavanaugh and Roberts gonna strike
down roe v wade in fact I'm very
skeptical that a case even allowing them
to strike down roe v wade makes the
Supreme Court the reason is because here
is the process of how a case reaches the
Supreme Court let's say that the state
of Montana decides that it wants to pass
a law banning abortion except to save
the life of the mother and that is
appealed to the Circuit Court of Appeals
and the Circuit Court of Appeals
applying roe v wade says this is
unconstitutional there's a right to an
abortion yada yada yada
now people on the right would say well
good let them do that
then it'll elevate to the Supreme Court
and then the Supreme Court will knock
down roe v wade itself and the law will
be protected there's only one problem it
takes four votes to actually determine
whether a case reaches the supreme court
so the way that the supreme court
determines whether to take a case in the
first place is that somebody appeals on
what's called the writ of certiorari and
in order for the in order for the
supreme court to grant a hearing on the
case four justices have to vote to hear
the case I don't think there are four
justices that would vote to hear a case
overturning roe v wade I think that if
it'd been Kony Barrett if it'd been Mike
Lee I think there would have been four
votes to hear the overturning of roe v
wade I think that because it is it is
not because it's Kavanagh I think
Kavanagh will work with Roberts to
create a sort of new middle of the court
now that middle of the court is not
going to be Justice Kennedy it's going
to be justice Souter it's not gonna be a
wild left middle of the court where
they're establishing rights to
ridiculous it's nonsense
just out of the box where it's not gonna
be that but it is gonna be is them
refusing to take really big broad huge
cases and instead it's going to be them
gradually scaling back the application
of roe v wade so instead of them just
striking down roe v wade letting the
chips fall where they may saying this is
a bad decision it's gone instead what
they probably will do is they will look
to a follow-up case to roe v wade called
Planned Parenthood versus Casey Planned
Parenthood versus Casey it was a case
that in which Justice Kennedy wrote the
decision it was it's a really crazy case
because there were about 83 different
opinions on the case the case was
decided in 1992 and basically it was a
plurality opinion and it decided that
roe v wade it is a opinion by O'Connor
and Kennedy and Souter right which is
why it's a garbage opinion it basically
decided that a state could pass a law
that restricted abortion so long as it
did not create an undue burden an undue
burden for the for the woman attempting
to get an abortion
so the actual standard is the undue
burden standard I'm find the exact
language they say quote we begin with
the standard as described in Casey we
recognize the state has legitimate
interest in seeing to it that abortion
like any other medical procedure is
performed under circumstances that
ensure maximum safety for the patient
they say unnecessary health regulations
that have the purpose or effect of
presenting a substantial obstacle
to a woman seeking an abortion impose an
undue burden on the right that's what
Planned Parenthood versus Casey says now
when that was decided it there were a
lot of folks on the right who thought
maybe this is the first step toward
curbing Roe that basically you get a
bunch of laws that carved back the
ability to get an abortion and the court
would just say well yeah it carves back
the ability to get an abortion but it's
not an undue burden on the right you can
still get an abortion in a variety of
other ways that's not what happened it's
not what happened but now there's the
suggestion that maybe that's what's
going to happen maybe the Supreme Court
won't take a case overtly overruling roe
v wade but the Supreme Court will take
cases where let's say there's a fetal
pain bill that says that you can't abort
a baby after the tenth week and the
Supreme Court takes that case and they
say well that doesn't present an undue
burden a woman can still get an abortion
she just has to do so in the first ten
weeks you could see that happening so
would that mean that the right has lost
that that the Constitution has lost well
the Constitution lost in the sense that
the Constitution ought to be the guiding
standard in roe v wade is a bad case and
you oughta just overrule it but these
sort of circumspect way in which I think
Cavanaugh and Roberts are going to
approach the law jointly suggests that
they will rule the right way but they
will do so slowly and gradually they're
much more concerned with doing things
slowly and gradually and incrementally
than they are and simply overruling
things outright now there's another
problem with incrementalism that I'm
gonna explain in just a second so the
big problem with incremental ism is that
once you create broad standards right
the left likes to create broad standards
obergefell saying that same-sex marriage
is now legal across the country abortion
saying that not just legal that that
states can't can't not perform same-sex
marriages across the country Roe versus
Wade saying that abortion is legal
across the country the left is never
afraid to use a bat when it comes to
creating judicial opinion they're never
afraid to go as broad as humanly
possible the right tends to pair that
stuff back kind of gradually but that
means that anytime the left gets control
of the court they immediately establish
a new right that the right only tends to
chip away at the edges regarding and
that to me is is always a net loss for
the right over time let's say that this
Court is solidly conservative or at
least solidly non liberal for the next
20 years well in that time are they how
much are they gonna pair back row v Wade
they're not gonna overrule it I don't
think how much are they gonna pair back
row v Wade how much are they gonna pair
back challenges to religious freedom
plus you only you really do have to make
hay while the Sun shines to a certain
extent remember
Justice Clarence Thomas who's the best
justice on the Supreme Court Bar None I
love Clarence Thomas's reasoning I think
it's a terrific judge Clarence Thomas is
seven years old he's gonna be 72 when
Donald Trump is up for reelection in
that means that if Donald Trump loses he
could be 80 by the time a Democrat
serves two terms god forbid so that
means that Thomas is now gonna have to
make some decisions because you got four
votes on the Supreme Court that are
solidly originalist maybe if you count
Cavanaugh and then he got Roberts he's
kind of a swing vote if Thomas goes and
he's replaced by somebody on the left
well that means that you've now got five
solid leftist votes to do anything that
they want to do so all the people on the
right who are saying well we're gonna
rule the court for a generation not
quite so fast not quite so fast right
depends what Clarence Thomas does
because Clarence Thomas is right at that
weird age where he's still got probably
five to ten years in him but at the same
time you never know right Justice Scalia
died prematurely at 76 so you never know
I and that the court has become sort of
this ghoulish death watch with regard to
all this sort of stuff you know we'll
see how Cavanaugh rules I don't think
that Cavanaugh is gonna be the gung-ho
Gorsuch figure that so many people
wanted but is it a win for president
Trump certainly a political win for
President Trump because Cavanaugh is
widely respected he's somebody who's
gonna pass through pretty easily
he's more reminiscent of Justice Roberts
than he is of Clarence Thomas in this
respect the Democrats were going nuts
over this whole thing are demonstrating
just how radical they are now the
Democrats didn't even wait to attack as
a part of this that's hilarious so Mitch
McConnell yesterday came out before
Trump had picked Cavanaugh and he said
in his inimitable boring fashion that
Democrats are going to attack no matter
what he's of course right but decades
later our Democratic colleagues still
haven't tired of crying wolf whenever a
Republican president nominates anyone
anyone to the Supreme Court tonight
President Trump will announce his
nominee to fill the current Supreme
Court vacancy we don't know who he will
name but we already know exactly what
unfair tactics the nominee will face and
the left is already jumping into unfair
tactics with regards to Cavanaugh
cocaine Mitch exactly on point right
there the fact is that they've already
started accusing Cavanaugh of wanting
to prevent Trump's impeachment there's
no legal basis for this number one if
Trump's impeached by a Congress he's
going to stay in page number two all
Cavanaugh said is that in 2009 Congress
should pass a law preventing the active
prosecution of the president while he's
in office because the impeachment
process is the way that the president
ought to be impeached it shouldn't be
done through legal means basically
through suing the president or or
through a prosecution of the president
but that's not a Supreme Court issue and
they're also going after Kavanaugh for
his involvement in the Kenneth Starr
case there's a piece from from a David
Brock book he can't believe David Brock
on anything David Brock of course is a
liar who worked for sort of Republican
constituencies until he flipped and
started working for Hillary Clinton he
suggested that at one point in the late
90s Brett Kavanaugh mailed the word
about Hillary Clinton if that's a
reason to if that's a reason to bar
somebody from the Supreme Court there
won't be a judge left in America
I mean seriously that's that's that's
ridiculous stuff but this is this is the
the level to which the left has sunk on
all this and you knew the left is gonna
go nuts no matter what so Jimmy Kimmel
of course he didn't know who was going
to be picked any films before the pic so
he suggested that Trump was going to
pick Voldemort because no matter who
Trump's pick it had to be evil in fact
it turns out to be a Catholic father of
two who volunteers at a soup kitchen but
he's actually Baltimore none of the
experts predicted this today I'm keeping
another promise to the American people
by nominating
[Music]
[Applause]
okay some yeah there it is anybody that
term nominates is gonna be Voldemort Ron
Perelman who is just an idiot and was
also a terrible bike gang leader on sons
of anarchy just really didn't fulfill
his responsibilities on that show in any
case he tweeted out okay ladies and
gentlemen who care for and respect
ladies it is official the move back to
medieval values Sharia law even where
old bitter men get to tell women what is
best for their bodies lives and
well-being as is done and well-being is
as done a deal as this is Twitter unless
we say no no oh those are all caps then
no one to know so a few problems with
this tweet besides the fact that we're
reading around Perelman tweet on-air huh
so there are a few problems number one
under Sharia law he would be jailed for
the sweet
I assume second of all I love it when
people say things like bitter old men
are gonna decide what women get to do
their bodies row v Wade was decided 72
the seven who voted in favor of roe v
wade were all men so there's that and
then also I like when he says that
women's bodies are going to be
controlled you see all these idiots who
are walking around in the red cloak and
the potato chip hat and the bonnet from
from had maids tail and I really think
that I'm gonna go into business I need
to go into business I I want a
government contract to be the sole
provider of red cloaks and bonnets for
the for the rest of this term and
hopefully for the next term as well I
think if I get a monopoly on that I
could become very wealthy indeed and and
you know I may as well make this into a
capitalistic enterprise as well as an
evil patriarchal one if we're if we're
gonna go this far I also love when Ron
Perlman says all this is going to happen
unless we say no no well guess what Ron
you just said no no it's gonna happen
anyway because bahahahahahaha
okay that's why because you lose okay
you rubes trump drinks your milkshake
that's what just happened right there
and the entire life cannot the entire
life cannot accept any of this I mean no
no millions will die terry mcauliffe a
government former governor of virginia
who now wants to run for president of
the united states after being hillary
clinton's waterboy for most of his
career he tweeted out the nomination of
Judge Brett Kavanaugh will threaten the
lives of millions of Americans for
decades to come
and
more far Supreme Court into a political
arm the right-wing Republican party yeah
I woke up this morning and I was driving
around and I thought for a second Terry
McAuliffe is red because there was no
one on the roads
I thought maybe ever been raptured and
they left me behind and then it turns
out it was just like 4:45 in the morning
cuz I was on Fox and Friends so it
wasn't that but I have been told that
I'm going to die because of the Paris
Accords I serve I have a t-shirt that
says this I survived the the
renegotiation of the Paris Accords I
survived net neutrality I mean look at
me man I survived the tax cuts I
survived it I survived night one of the
Cavanaugh collapse I survived night one
ok this purge like state in which we all
live we're a DC white-shoe lawyer who
went to Harvard Law School and has
worked with a bunch of lefties on the
court for years and years and years I
survived it and you did too it's just
the most Hardy of us just the bravest of
us so I don't know whether I've just
developed an immunity to all of these
horrible things happening in our country
because I've been working out or
something and really taking my meds or
maybe it's that the left has completely
lost their mind on all of this stupid
garbage but it's whatever it is really
you're gonna get exercised over Brett
Kavanaugh like I got a honestly I
understood when the left is getting all
mad about Charlottesville I got it
because I think that Trump was wrong
about Charlottesville but when they go
like nuts over a guy who was endorsed by
a killer Itamar in the pages of the New
York Times the killer Itamar is a
left-wing legal scholar from Yale give
me a break just just give me a freaking
break we'll get some more of left-wing
reaction in just a second first you're
gonna have to go over to Daley we're
calm and subscribe for $9.99 a month
you'll get a subscription to daily wire
when you do you get the rest of the show
live the rest of Michael Moses show live
the rest of Andrew clavin's show live
and you get to be part of our mailbag
whenever we have our mailbag you get to
ask us live questions we had an extra
episode last night of the show you got
to ask questions during the break so
that was a lot of fun so become a
subscriber be part of the club and you
get this the leftist here's how to hold
tumblr when you get the annual
subscription and let me tell you this
thing is extraordinarily heavy today
because it is filled to the brim with
leftist tears
magnificent magnificent leftist tears
both hot and cold in fact this is almost
burning my hand but the quality of this
tumblr keeps the temperature down around
my hand because otherwise it would just
be red-hot leftist tears as
as they are pouring in to check all that
out please subscribe also at YouTube or
iTunes leave us a review it always helps
us we had largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so Senator Chuck Schumer says that it's
all at stake we're all gonna die
and this is Chuck Schumer teen doubt
what's hilarious about this is the Chuck
Schumer as you'll recall tried to
filibuster Neil Gorsuch because that was
gonna end the world - that failed and
now he's gonna try and filibuster and
fail Brett Kavanaugh that's gonna fail -
here is here's Chuck Schumer saying the
freedom of women is at stake women are
about to be arrested they are about to
me made handmaidens they're about to be
enslaved they really are they because
weird I'm not seeing any of those things
happening but here's Chuck Schumer
everyone orders understand what it means
for the freedom of women to make their
own healthcare decisions and for the
protection for Americans with
pre-existing conditions those rights
will be gravely threatened gravely
threatened by the fact that people can
vote on them ooh ooh people might vote
better not have that let's get some
justices on there who will ensure that
we can never vote on any of the crucial
issues of our time and then Schumer says
in precise contravention of what Trump
said about personal views on the
judiciary Trump had said I don't care
about personal views I care about
enforcement of the Constitution Schumer
says we need to know your personal views
your personal views are all that matters
and this is because the left believes
the personal is political they believe
that any opinion you hold as a judge
actually comes out in how you rule so if
you are anti-abortion but you believe
Rovi ways rightly decided it matters
more that you are personally
anti-abortion this is nonsensical of
course and the left doesn't even believe
that what they really want is guarantee
that the right is not going to rule
according to the Constitution they're
not going to get that guarantee the left
was so all-fired angry over this
preemptively so protesters arrived early
last night at the Supreme Court Trump
had not even appointed his guy they were
out there protesting and they didn't
know who had been appointed yet okay
here's some audio of them making fools
of themselves
[Applause]
and then the weird and there's always
that one weird guy who's got like the
anti circumcision sign which is like I
don't even realize that was something
being appealed to the Supreme Court's
that's that's good to know good to know
that the chop-chop is definitely going
to be is gonna be at the tip of
everybody's mind
that's it I'm just I'm so confused but
the left is now so they've done denial
now they are in the middle of anger so
anger involves conspiratorial thinking
so Cory Booker who is just a wild man
Cory Booker the senator from New Jersey
and the man with a fictional best
friends who is a gang member
so Cory Booker he says that Trump is
choosing Brett Kavanaugh not because
Brett Kavanaugh is a well-established
legal mind inside the DC Beltway and was
pushed by Leonard Leo and Dom McGann the
White House Counsel know the reason that
Trump is choosing Brett Kavanaugh is
because Brett Kavanaugh is going to help
Trump avoid impeachment by what
hijacking the marshal of the US Supreme
Court and arresting Cory Booker or Brett
Kavanaugh actually is Voldemort he's
gonna take out his magic wand and lose
his nose and somehow save President
Trump
here's Cory Booker being a complete
whack job he has a lot of other legal
trouble and the challenges that this
president could have caused for himself
now he's got it that insurance policy
he's got this get-out-of-jail-free card
if you if you will Brett Kavanaugh as he
got out of jail what's their legal
theory is that there's an impeachment
hearing Trump gets impeached and it goes
to the Supreme Court in the supreme
court overrules that cuz a Kavanagh yeah
yeah that's gonna happen and aurora's
his legal theory that Muller will come
down with an indictment and then
Cavanaugh will rule then no indictment
can move forward except that there
aren't the votes on the Supreme Court
for that and Cavanaugh doesn't even
agree with that and the piece that he
wrote in 2009 about prosecution of
President suggested that Congress should
make the law protecting the president
not that the judiciary could protect the
president from such prosecution but
never mind the conspiracies have to rule
so Blumenthal Richard Blumenthal the
senator from Connecticut he says that
the same thing right Trump is going to
let the next justice pardon himself Rudy
Giuliani raising the possibility of a
pardon this next justice will sit on
the issue of whether or not the
president can pardon himself or others
okay so it's going to be that he's going
to trump's gonna pardon himself and
cavanaugh will help hold this stuff the
conspiracy theories from the left are
just out of control
my favorite conspiracy theory is this
one from Neera tanden Neera tanden
is one of the foolish leaders of the
women's march and the head of the Center
for American Progress and she tweeted
out Justice Kennedy's son made a billion
dollars in loans to trump from the
Russia infested and sanction Deutsche
Bank so now I'm not even I'm so confused
about what this conspiracy theory even
is the conspiracy theory is that Justice
Kennedy's son made a loan to Trump and
therefore Trump leveraged Kennedy into
leaving so that he could bring on Brett
Kavanaugh when I loan you money you
don't then get to leverage me into
anything because I loaned you the money
and also if I were gonna loan you money
and then you were going to exercise
leverage over me wouldn't the leverage
mostly involve you telling me how to
decide cases not to resign why would you
give up that none of this makes any
sense but the left is not interested in
making sense they're interested in
screaming as loudly as possible at the
moon convinced that in doing so they
will somehow transform themselves into
werewolves and thereby bring about the
the the thwarting of the Cavanaugh
collapse so it's it's all it's all
insanity meanwhile to show how extreme
left is Michelle wolf continues to make
a fool of herself so this of course is
the comedian from from Netflix alleged
comedian I should say because I don't
want to be sued for libel by calling her
a comedian I don't think that she she
fits the bill so Michelle wolf the only
person in America with more annoying
voice than mine she goes on the Netflix
and she's talking about abortion
remember she already said abortion was
the sacrament yesterday she said god
bless abortion now she says that
abortion is not killing a baby
don't you understand abortion doesn't
kill babies abortion merely stops a baby
from happening some people say abortion
is killing a baby it's not it's stopping
a baby from happening okay some people
say the Michelle wolf is killing comedy
she's not she's just stopping comedy
from happening
she's prematurely terminating comedy hey
it's it that comedy was never it was
never alive that comedy it was it was
just a
of words before and she got rid of it
before it could ever form itself into an
actual joke she actually just terminated
the joke a little bit early to prevent
it from ever taking full form and you
can't really accuse sort of killing the
joke per se she really just stopped the
formation of the joke now you may say
Michelle wolf
why weren't you just abstinent from
comedy why didn't why didn't you just
use a little bit protection why did you
wait until the joke started to be formed
before you carved it apart in the womb
and flushed it down the toilet why
didn't you just do that but that would
be patriarchal to suggest that you are
in control of Michelle Wolf's comedic
decisions right Michelle wolf gets to be
as promiscuous with comedy as she could
possibly want to be and then she gets to
terminate the results of that comedy
before it forms into comedy because
after all it's just the same as a polyp
it's basically the same as any other
sentence that comedic joke okay so
Michelle wolf but she is indicative of a
mindset that is said in among people on
the Left which is that abortion is the
ultimate good and that's why they're so
imagining the reason they're so mad
today is because for folks on the Left
abortion has taken on an actual morally
positive hue it's not just that abortion
is something we need in cases of
something going wrong it's something we
need in terrible horrible cases you know
that's that's an old-fashioned argument
you know there used to be people who
argued that abortion was necessary
because of rape and incest right this
was always the argument that was used
now as a pro-life person I don't believe
that rape and incest are actually in an
excuse for an abortion I believe that
rape ought to be punishable by a
castration death life imprisonment and I
believe that incest ought to be
punishable by force of law but that
doesn't mean that you get to actually
kill a baby because the creation of the
baby was something horrible and evil
that said they used to be the left use
those are the excuses they said well you
know they're they're really hard moral
situations where you have to make
compromises
now the left says if you have not had an
abortion then you are doing something
wrong you aren't you're living by the
stereotype that you ought to be pregnant
and by doing so you are reinforcing the
patriarchy it's men making decisions
over your body the best kind of woman
the most empowered kind of woman is the
woman who's had an abortion the woman
who's had an abortion is better a better
version of the woman and the woman who's
never had an abortion because the woman
who's never had an abortion you know she
really has has not accepted that her
body is under her own control it's a
sign of female empowerment just the same
way that the left has decided that women
who part
paetynn pornography or prostitutes are
actually avatars of female empowerment
because they are empowered with their
own body well being pregnant and then
killing the baby that is another way of
feeling proud of your own body because
after all the baby who's not an
independent human being that's just a
part of your body and so when you kill
it you're not actually killing it you're
just stopping it from happening and I
love the euphemisms the left uses
stopping it from happening right oh gee
Simpson didn't kill Nicole Nicole Brown
Simpson he just stopped her from
happening and he just he just stopped
her I mean he she was there and then she
wasn't but it was mostly that she was
happening and then suddenly she just
stopped happening it was a thing that
wasn't happening anymore was Nicole
Brown it's just the the levels of lie
that the left will tell about abortion
in order to maintain it as a sacrament
are truly astonishing and that's why
when I see people you know on the right
who continue to maintain that the right
should not engage in this particular
battle I say this may be the only
important moral battle that's gonna
matter a thousand years from now a
thousand years from now people aren't
going to care about what the tax rate
was in the United States in 2018 a
thousand years from now people are not
truly going to care very much about
environmental policy in the United
States and the Minor differentiations
between cave standards what people are
definitely going to care about is
whether we as a society decided to green
light and not only green light
celebrates the murder of the unborn and
this is why I think that I wish
Kavanaugh would overrule roe v wade I
think that we're gonna move in the
direction of curbing roe v wade which is
better than nothing but I think it would
be better if we just got rid of it and
and stopped killing you know thirty five
hundred babies a day in the United
States it seems to me the dad should
have been the unending ol here I hope
the Cavanaugh proves me wrong maybe he
will we'll find out okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like today I
speaking of the Supreme Court William
Rehnquist was Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court until Justice John Roberts
was appointed back in 2005 he wrote this
is the first book I ever read on the
Supreme Court I actually bought it at
the Supreme Court
it's called the Supreme Court by William
Rehnquist and it is it is a good guide
to how everything works at the Supreme
Court it also has some it has some good
content on the history of the Supreme
Court and what it's like to work at the
Supreme Court and it's a really good
kind of primer for anybody who's
interested in the basics of how the
Supreme Court operates Rehnquist himself
is an interesting judge he wasn't an
originalist he wasn't really a
textualist
he was
of a conservative if you were gonna say
that he was politically oriented and
sort of law and order conservative who
believed that all of the attempts to
undermine law and order the liberal
interpretation the Constitution were
misguided he tended to vote consistently
you know with conservative positions on
the court but his opinions were never
Scalia or Thomas rooted in the history
and context of the Constitution per se
but he did move the court in a more
conservative direction I think that if
you were gonna find a somebody who
you're gonna liken to Cavanaugh I think
the Rehnquist is probably the best comp
in baseball or basketball you say okay
you're drew you have a draft pick who
does that draft pick pencil out - who's
that draft pick become is it Anthony
Davis or does this person pencil out -
celebrant or does this person pencil out
- Brian Scalabrine well when it comes to
Justice Roberts you know I said that he
was gonna pencil out a lot more like
Souter he penciled out somewhere between
Souter and and Rehnquist I think that
the chances are pretty good that cabinet
ends up as a Rehnquist figure which is
something conservatives should be happy
with I wouldn't say ecstatic about okay
time for a couple of one more thing that
I like so I don't know why it is that
Colton has decided to bring me a weird
story today but he's decided to bring me
a weird story every day this is a story
from w ng o ABC in New Orleans where
nard Mathews was killed in New Orleans
two weeks ago he was young
18 years old and while the tragedy of
losing him so young weighs heavily on
his family they chose to have his body
prepared for Sunday's afternoon's wake
in a way that they want to remember him
when the Charbonnet labott Glapion
funeral home in dream Matthews was
sitting in a chair video game controller
in hands surrounded by his favorite
snacks and his beloved Boston Celtics on
the television screen and if you can't
see this folks this is literally a dead
guy who's sitting in the chair with a
game controller on his lap and a box of
chip crunch beneath his chair and and a
video of the Golden State Warriors
playing the Boston Celtics on television
and it's it's video game is is it a
video game of the Warriors playing the
Celtics
well the Celtics are losing because
presumably he can't actually move the
controller so that's a game he is
destined to lose right there he seems
rather unenthusiastic about the game
perhaps that is because he is dead
I will give it to the family at least
hehe was posed to doing what he loved so
that's that's exciting he he's he's it's
full weekend at bernie's over there and
in New Orleans and it does make you
think like if this were Bill Clinton you
probably couldn't pose him in public
doing what he loved right would be it'd
be a real problem he'd just be Bill
Clinton with his zipper down holding a
cigar and then just sitting in a chair
and then Hillary presumably Hillary
Clinton screaming at him screaming at
his corpse I could imagine the various
the various public figures what like
what would you do it Kevin Spacey's
funeral you just do it doing what you
loved Harvey Weinstein's funeral like
just I think we should probably not do
this I think that just as a general rule
societally we probably should not do
this we probably should just stick you
in a box
yeah this is some well to move it's a
move I'll give him that it's a it's a
thing that happened in the United States
yep and it's gotta be kind of weird
because you walk into that funeral
you're like do I go over and say hello
like do I congratulate him on how the
game is going and I like that they have
velvet ropes that actually block off the
crowd from the body to make sure that
people don't go there and like repose
him right they're gonna go there and
like put his hand on his crotch or
something or they or they're going to or
they're gonna put like a pom pom in his
hand because he's rooting for the team
it's a yeah yeah this seems like this
seems like not a not a great thing okay
so time for some things that I hate the
thing that I hate today is the Louvre
the Louvre what are you doing okay first
of all your barn second of all I don't
understand why it is that you are paying
homage to jay-z and Beyonce so a couple
of weeks ago I did a deconstructing the
culture in which I went through the the
ape bleep video ape crap video a poop
video right because it's a video okay so
we went through that a couple of weeks
ago because it's ridiculous Rolling
Stones did a whole analysis of why
Beyonce thrashing about in her
undergarments in the middle of Louvre
somehow outclasses the work of Leonardo
da Vinci and how Western art had been
completely put to shame by jay-z
standing there like a catatonic idiot
while his wife flounce is about in these
giant drapes that look like they were
bought at the bed bathroom
beyond from next door right so for so
it's a really bad music video the Louvre
has decided that they are going to
actually now do a tour of the Louvre
based on a video called ape poop about
have you ever heard a crowd going ape
poop and a bunch of half-naked people
doing gyrating motions in front of great
art the Louvre you suck so here is the
New York Post here's what they say
everything is love between the Carters
and the Louvre beyonce and jay z's ate
bleep video has racked up 61 million
views and Counting in just the past
three weeks because in large part
because the music video is showing the
power couple dancing among masterpieces
such as da Vinci's Mona Lisa and the
Venus de Milo and the Parisian Fine Arts
Museum is a visual feast a visual feast
really more like a visual Last Supper
because afterward somebody is going to
get it okay now the Louvre is
capitalizing on its new street cred by
offering a free self-guided tour of 17
paintings and statues featured
prominently in the first video off of
the carters new album everything is love
including the winged victory of
samothrace statue the Beyonce Vogue's in
front of while wearing a hundred and
forty thousand dollars to fan rollin
wedding dress that sucker crossed a
hundred and forty thousand dollars I
have a question these are these are the
people of the people is like what the
people want the lady thrashing about in
front of winged victory of samothrace
wearing a hundred and forty thousand
dollar wedding dress she's aren't even
married for several years like he
couldn't give him that to charity and
just going to the Salvation Army picked
up a tablecloth lady my goodness and she
apparently also Murray Ben West's
portrait of a the 90-minute
self-guided audio tour
gysi at the people saying oh who is
currently only in French but other
languages will eventually be available
or you can translate the torn your
internet browser using plugins like
Chrome's translate feature the guide
identifies each work of art and gives
its historical context well I'm sure
that I'm sure that jay-z and Beyonce
knew the full historical context and I'm
sure that when they were screaming about
going ape bleep amongst the half nude
bodies gyrating in front of these
paintings they were they're really
thinking about how can I get more
tourists to see the winged victory of
samothrace by the way well in forget
forget like a hundred years in five
minutes when no one cares about this
video that statue will still be there
because that's what statues are made for
permanence and
it's an amazing piece of art the Louvre
wasn't hurting for attention eight
million people visited the world-class
cultural institution last year 1 million
of them came from the US more than half
were under the age of 30 but the Carters
are one of the world's most powerful
couple says the New York Post with a 1.6
billion dollar combined net worth last
year so why can't they afford better
clothes may they spend a hundred and
forty thousand dollars I'm not gonna get
over the fact that that dress cost 140
thousand dollars I'm just not it looks
like she was it was like she was swamped
by a by a an opaque jellyfish beyonce
boasts more than 113 million Instagram
followers and one social media post from
her is worth 1 million dollars in
advertising because everything is not
love everything is stupid so there's
celebrity endorsement inspires their
fans who haven't crossed the Atlantic to
consider making the trek to the Louvre
and the video also showcases works of
art apart from the Mona Lisa which those
who visited the museum already may have
missed so this can encourage them to
return syracuse university professor and
pop culture expert Robert Thompson told
money ish Beyonce and jay-z have
essentially become backdoor curators of
one of the world's greatest art
collections because they've taken those
17 works and suddenly escalated them to
the top of the Louvre it's true nobody
had heard of the Mona Lisa or the winged
victory of samothrace until Beyonce and
jay-z it wasn't like they were in the
world's most famous be oh yeah it turns
out that 8 million people a year saw
those things because they're in the
world's most famous Museum yeah the
Louvre 17 must-see pieces are now the
ones that they chose their own Greatest
Hits marketing expert mark sab Lau CEO
cogent entertainment marketing agreed
the Louvre is already a massive tourist
attraction now it is an Instagram
attraction for all pop culture junkies
great I want more idiot Millennials
taking selfies in their sunglasses while
gyrating in front of great statues
that's what Western art is all about
says the Carters are the new framers
that would be the series of guidebooks
but their songs acting as travel guides
to must-see cultural experiences well
technically something solely acting as a
Travel Guide it's more than music video
the song itself acts only as a Travel
Guide to actual ape crap so there's that
and they are apparently making the
museum accessible to a wider audience
because no one had heard of the Louvre
before they've made it accessible says
the Carters could potentially bring in a
whole new audience of people by the way
I don't know that um that would actually
be what the Carters intended considering
that I thought according to Rolling
Stone the whole thing was supposed to be
mocking the insularity an archaic nature
of Western art that all this Western art
was based on white people but here are
brown and black bodies and
of the art and therefore drawing a
contrast between the live bodies and the
dead portrayals of those bodies on the
walls of the Louvre that was Rolling
Stones take so I guess there's a
different take which is that apparently
Beyonce and juicy love Western art the
Louvre has benefited from star power
before of course it was featured in The
Da Vinci Code and and of course it was
in Night at the Museum as Museum of
Natural History was in Night at the
Museum right the difference is that none
of it was really about like mocking the
art itself the Brooklyn Museum is in the
middle of the David Bowie is exhibit of
a exhibition of 400 objects including 60
custom-made performance costumes
handwritten lyrics sheets and drawings
from the late music icons a personal
archive okay I guess all advanced
tickets are sold out like people have
nothing to do I think that this is the
conclusion I've come to people have
nothing to do that you gotta go see
David Bowie's costumes you know what
honey I've got nothing to do it's a
Sunday morning let's go see David
Bowie's costumes okay or I could shoot
myself in the face I mean what okay okay
I get it
some your David Bowie fans all right all
I'm saying is that the the attempt to
turn great art into a backdrop for bad
art and then use that bad art as oh look
at them they're patrons of the Arts
Oh Louvre Louvre now the French what can
you do with them all right we'll be back
here tomorrow with all the latest I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing